اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم بعثت الامم المتحده الى
السودان تدين مقتل والي غردافور وتدعو
لتقديم الجنات للعداله فورا وتقول ان
افادات مقنعه تنسب مقتله الى الميليشيات
العربيه وقوات الدعم السريع مصدر في
الخارجيه السودانيه يقول للجزيره ان
الخرطوم ابلغت منظمه ايجاد رفضها رئاسه
كينيا للجنه ازمه السودان وتتهمها بعدم
الحياد على وقع اشتباكات ضاريه في
اوكرانيا وهجمات بالمسيرات في القرن
القوات الاوكرانيه تقول انها تتقدم في
الجبهه الجنوبيه الشرقيه موسكو تقول ان
استخدامها السلاح النووي ممكن للاغراض
الدفاعيه بينما شدد الناتو على ان دعم
الحلف لكييف يحدث فارقا في الحرب
طوكيو تؤكد سقوط صاروخين اطلقتهما كوريا
الشماليه في منطقتها البحريه الخالصه وتصف
ذلك بالانتهاك التاريخ للامن ولقرارات
الامم المتحده في حين وصفت سول المسلكه
الكوريه الشمالي بانه احتجاج على
مناوراتها الاخيره مع واشنطن
روسواحل اليونانيه يقول ان 79 شخصا لقوا
مصرعهم
يقل مئات المهاجرين قباله السواحل
الجنوبيه الغربيه للبلاد في كارثه جديده
للمهاجرين للمتوسط مشيرا الى ان عمليات
الاغاثه للقارب ادت الى انقاذ 104 اشخاص
مع استمرار عمليات البحث عن مفقودين الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]